let's go to connor in philadelphia
connor what's up brother how are we
doing
oh i'm doing all right uh thank you so
much for taking my call dr john hey
brother thanks for calling in how can i
help
so i have a hard subject in my family
but my wife and my mother-in-law they
have a really shaky relationship
they actually haven't talked in about
four years uh after our first daughter
was born we have two children
and her mother has been addicted to
prescription pain medications and abused
fentanyl and
morphine for over 15 years and i just
see my wife struggling every day
with her relationship and not talking to
her mother but
we don't know what to do okay so
mom's been an addict for 15 years is is
there any movement there any desire
to not do that anymore or is it just is
what it is what it is
so you know about four years ago what
what prompted her to stop talking to her
is you know her and
i said you know we can't just ignore the
problem right and right let's sit down
and talk to her and we sat down we
talked to her
mother completely exploded yep you know
adamantly denies i'm not addicted i'm
prescribed this medication but she takes
more than she's prescribed
she she uses multiple pain patches at
the time
she's definitely abusing it and it's
she's lost everything physically
she's deteriorating financially
emotionally she'll
she'll pass out in the middle of
conversations that we're having she'll
pass out while our children are there
it's just it's a mess and you know she
exploded at us
kicked us out and you know pretty much
that was the end of the last time we
spoke to her and that was in 2016.
yeah so i'm going to give you some hard
truth brother you probably know what i'm
going to say but
i know it helps to hear it from an
outside source
you cannot have a functioning
relationship with an addict
yep you can't she needs connection she
needs
love she needs people to keep showing up
and showing up and showing up
that may not be you guys right now with
small kids
and that's especially painful for a guy
like you who desperately loves his wife
and whose wife desperately wants her
mama to be involved in the raising of
the two small kids
having a grandmother that's around right
this whole
norman rockwell fantasy picture is gone
because somebody's an addict
and i'm not in the business of blaming
addicts
i can't imagine the story that your
grandma's experienced
and the the numbing and the
ability to distance herself from those
that pain that that fentanyl and some of
that nonsense can provide
but the reality is your job is taking
care of your kids and loving your wife
the best that you can
and you can't do that in relationship
with a functioning addict
yeah what hurts the most you know and
and i
we my wife thank god she you know she
she works in the medical field and she
knows that stuff i think that
the challenge for us is you know i i see
her hurting
and i want to help my wife i know
there's something to do for her but
is there anything i could do for my wife
to try to help her cope with it
yeah there's a there's a a couple of
things one is
you can know this intellectually as a
helping professional
right i know a lot of things but it
doesn't mean it doesn't really hurt
when my wife says something right or
when i call home and
my parents are working on something
right it still hurts
and that idea of knowing intellectually
in your frontal lobe
versus feeling and your amygdala is not
sending off signals that you're
disconnected you're disconnected you're
just connected
so a couple of things one is i'm gonna
recommend that you
this is just this is just husband to
husband dad to dad
that you yourself set an example
not through advice not through hey you
know what you should be doing but that
you go see a counselor
and when your wife asks you what you're
doing why you're doing it
tell her i love you
and i love our kids and i'm really
haunted by this situation that
they're going to grow up without a
grandma and i want to know how to love
you better and i want to know how to
love these kids better
and that's going to be a
signal to her that you are deeply
tethered in and that you're invested
and at the end of the day all you can
control is you right that's it
and so you're going to get some tools
and some relationship
ideas and some new strategies on how to
love better
but you're also going to signal to your
wife that we've got to put the fantasy
to bed
it's over the second thing is is i want
you to be somebody who offers
strong boundaries meaning you've got to
sit down with your wife and say
all right let's this is 15-year
addiction this is a four years we're not
talking
at the end of the day there's not a lot
we can do here maybe there's brothers
and sisters who can help with
intervention
maybe there's your you know your
father-in-law is willing to help help
you know and go all in with the army
that's that's one option
but it sounds like you need to sit down
with your wife and you all need to paint
a new picture of what thanksgiving is
going to look like without grandma
forever
you're going to need to paint a picture
of kids growing up not knowing who the
grandma was
or only seeing them every once in a
while because grandma
checked out right for whatever reason um
knowing that when your wife is
frustrated or she breaks down in tears
that she doesn't need advice from you
she just needs a hug from you to say i
love you and this sucks
it's not supposed to be that way moms
are supposed to be connected with their
daughters moms are supposed to be
invested in their grandkids life
and y'all aren't going to get that and
it's less about trying to fix it your
your wife knows what's up she's smart
she's brilliant she married a wise guy
like you
um man it just sucks it's just a matter
of being with her
when i tell you you got to put the
fantasy down my guess is
after four years y'all have had this
conversation how is it going
so it's exactly what you said
you know there are times where you know
we've we've
we've said it you know we've said this
isn't this is not a safe place for our
children to be
though the way that she behaves and acts
now being addicted is is not it's
unsafe for our children and we can't i
can't bring a one-year-old and a
four-year-old around there
okay and hey listen listen listen
listen that's a big deal that you just
said that good for you
there's too many people who are trying
to live out a fantasy live out a
i wish it was i wish it would and they
are trying to cram
a triangle through a square hole
man they're trying to take a like a
round peg and just
mash it through a triangle hole brother
and you've done some hard things by
saying that my kids aren't safe i'm not
doing it
good for you good for you yeah i
appreciate that and
you know it's it's hard and what makes
it even more challenging i think is my
my wife has memories pre-addiction and
how great her mother was
yeah and my mother passed away from
cancer when i
before i even met my wife so you know
our children don't have a grandmother
my mother-in-law is divorced from from
my father-in-law
from this like you know so
it's just it's almost like a death of a
family member hey listen listen listen
while they're still living it's exactly
like a death of a family member
and except it's worse because you're
right they're still alive
you can't properly grieve it and move on
and so what you and your wife have got
to do brother you have got to grieve it
maybe even have a small ceremony and i
don't mean that tongue-in-cheek i mean
a true ceremony that you and your wife
go somewhere
you celebrate a memory she had of mom
before addiction
when mom was whole and mom was safe and
mom was warm
and you you mourn the passing of that
you grieve it
and you cry like you haven't cried i'd
recommend that your wife write
a couple of letters that she's never
gonna give her her mom
but write her mom a letter of anger
here's what you're missing
here's the beautiful babies you're
missing here's the
here's the narratives you're missing and
i wanted to write a second letter which
is here's who i'm going to be
i'm going to be uh incredible mom i'm
never going to be an addict
i'm going to do these things i'm going
to go to counseling i'm going to double
down on my husband
i'm going to be an extraordinary
woman and let those things rest and then
y'all grieve the loss of your mom
i mean if your mother-in-law sucks
brother it sucks
here's the thing there is no way to
avoid the pain of this
because it's a living breathing hurt
it just is again brother i want to
commend you for being a great husband
for being an invested husband for
trying to love your wife the best you
can grieve this thing
let go of the fantasy and then start
building a new world that may mean
finding some older ladies at church who
become surrogate grandmothers
um i've i had two grandmothers living
and my son
when he was five and six made best
friends
it was like reverse dennis the menace he
made best friends
with an elderly woman who lived next
door to us she'd give him fig newtons
and he would
cut her little weeds with some some
scissors that she gave him and they
would chit chat for hours it was just
really beautiful together and there we
haven't lived in that town for several
years
and we still write letters we still get
notes um
and it's just a matter of finding
somebody else to get invested in your
kids life
there's women out there who would love
to do that they're surrogate granddads
who
love to be invested but it's a matter of
finding that but don't go run find those
things until you've grieved the loss
and i'll also put this out there for
folks who have addiction in their family
it's gonna sound like i'm talking out of
both sides of my mouth but don't give up
don't give up on people keep praying for
folks
you can send cards you can send letters
that say i love you
if you've got brothers and sisters who
want to reach out and do an intervention
you can do that
but protect your hearts because the
reality is especially with
with fentanyl and galilee man
you know prescription drugs addictions
those things are demons that just
drown family members drown family
members
and to doctors he keep writing that
nonsense man stop
stop quit doing that man you're
destroying families
help people get well don't just dope
them up to the point that they become
non-functional unsafe grandparents stop
man